so the question is can someone stop
being lazy there's a part of me that
says yes there's a part of me that says
no you'll find out what that is there's
three things I'm going to reference one
a book two stories then the third one's
gonna be a movie I just watched I was so
pissed off at the end Mario wanted to go
watch this movie with me I agreed we
went acting was phenomenal the whale
Brandon Frazier crushed it but I hated
the movie specifically the end and I'll
tell you why spoiler don't watch this
video if you're planning on watching the
movie it's probably going to be a waste
of time because I'm going to tell you
exactly what happens at the end so
having said that let's get right into it
if you get value from this video give it
a thumbs up and subscribe to this
Channel I want to give a quick shout out
today to our sponsor Masterworks here's
why for the longest time you and I maybe
didn't trust art but we appreciated it
right for long example cards collectible
cards why would I buy a card what if
it's not real what if it's not this then
all of a sudden credibility enter the
market for collectible cards and art SCC
got involved PSA got involved and next
thing you know alternative Investments
went to the roof private Equity got into
to Adventure Capital got into it Goldman
Sachs is now sitting there there's now
art funds there's funds that is about
investing into certain pieces of art for
high-end clients last year was a
record-breaking year in art 18 billion
dollars of art was purchased last year
it was the biggest auction year ever
nearly 18 billion dollars say now you
may watch this in Pat 18 billion Square
I don't have that kind of money I don't
yeah but just the same way you buy a
mutual fund or a stock of a company what
if now you can buy a piece of a Picasso
painting or A bank's a piece of art that
he has how cool would that be and then
if it grows your investment also grows
for you that's what Masterworks does
they allow you to invest in this
multi-million dollar art for a fraction
of a full price and they qualify each
offering with the SEC which you can find
at Edgar database at sec.gov and Linked
In the description will be below so if
you do want to learn more about
Masterworks click on the link below
there's a special offer specifically for
the audience of valuetainment so I'm at
an event last week San Antonio or
Houston I'm giving a speech and every
time I go through these January
conventions conferences there's a group
of people that I know when I talk to
them they're going to tell me the same
thing every time so how was your numbers
how'd you finish off to your old Pat if
you only knew what I went through in
2022 but 2023 is going to be big as if
2023 is not going to have new sets of
problems right no you if you only know
what I went through in 20 20 22 is very
hard for us very we went through so many
difficulties I'm like
four years straight your script is the
same it's as if you want to go on stage
to justify why you didn't perform by the
way lazy people like to do that to
justify why their numbers aren't good
because life is so hard I'm going
through really tough times right now my
relationships with this with that no
problem so I get on stage I have a whole
speech mapped out I'm like okay I'm
going to change it up I'm going to open
up with a different story I said hey I
want you to write down the three biggest
problems you faced in 2022 30 seconds
everybody gets a minute they're writing
it down
I said now here's the game we're going
to play you got your set of problems I'm
going to give you three tell me if you'd
like to exchange your three problems for
the three problems I'm gonna give you
good yeah okay fantastic I want you to
think about your a 15 year old boy
your mother dies at 15 years old okay
you watch or die I want you to think
about your a 35 year old man 36 year old
father man husband
you had a soccer game your 15 year old
younger brother who's a great soccer
player gets hit with the soccer ball in
a regular soccer match he collapses in
the middle of the game goes to the
hospital dies at 15 years old younger
brother then six months later your
father dies from brain cancer okay you
have your problems I got these three
problems for you would you exchange your
three problems with these problems
nobody raised your hands so the reason
why I give it a story is because there's
a guy right there Adam stand up his name
is Christian I said that's exactly what
he went through last year that's exactly
what he went through in his life the
brother and his father that just
happened last 12 to 24 months I said he
needs the MVP of the entire group here
2 000 people in the room he ended up
becoming the MVP in the entire group
everybody's like silence in the room
there's nothing to say you know why one
of the biggest signs of laziness is we
have convinced ourselves our life is so
hard and that is our out
and stories like that annoy because I
guarantee you no matter how hard you
think you're like you if you know how my
dad was
if you know how my mom was
husband did to me my wife did to me my
kid do you know who just passed me you
know who this do you know who that I
totally get it life sucks sometimes it's
hard to be a father sometimes it's hard
to be a son it's hard to be a husband
it's hard to be a woman a man it's hard
it's not supposed to be easy it's just
not but every time clinging on that idea
that your life so is so much harder than
somebody else's while somebody with a
heart of life than you is winning and
I'm making excuses so number one is that
story let me go to the second one can
somebody choose to stop being lazy I
think it's all going to come down to one
thing a book I read a long time ago I'm
going to reference yeah reference as
much as I can I like to reference this
book It's called Power versus Force when
you're looking at the screen there are
different levels that goes through that
gets somebody to be willing to change so
it talks about levels of consciousness
there's a level above 200 where you're
becoming a leader anything below you're
not the lowest level starts with shame
you're ashamed okay we all at some point
have been shamed the next one is guilt
nobody does anything good that feels
guilty okay for something you did in the
past then there's apathy right then
there's grief there's fear there's
desire there's anger there's Pride if
you have any of those which we all have
you're not going to change your pride
your ego I'm wrong anger desire grief
you don't know I feel sorry for me you
ain't changing you you are not changing
the first level of change that it talks
about in the book is courage one has to
have courage to stop being lazy right
after courage is neutrality which means
being willing to receive different
arguments of people to say here's what I
think you ought to consider doing so you
got courage neutrality then it's
willingness I am willing to improve then
it's acceptance I am willing to accept
that I've been lazy the last two years
and I want to do something about it then
after acceptance is reason let's reason
on what I need to do improve right so
the part of me that says yeah this
person can change that person can change
is the following reason you know how so
many people DM and say I love to work
with Elon Musk I'd love to work with
Michael Jordan man I love to work I'd
love to be Brady's teammate I love to
work with you Pat I'd love to be at the
office with you seen exactly what you're
doing really yeah okay what do you think
it's like to work with jobs
you think jobs is always sitting there
saying imagine if one day Apple builds a
phone and you're like hey what a
Visionary did you feel that I felt it or
do you think it's like hey I want you
guys to take something a computer this
big ass computer and I want you to fit
it in this
you got six months
what a [__] who are you to say
something like that if you're so smart
why don't you do it you need to do it
you don't do it you're fired
that's how Steve would be
I don't see him being like that I see
him seeing saying stuff like but I
believe you guys got this
because I just feel it let's do yoga to
get and take some LSD and let some make
some smartphones together no
you may have worked with somebody that's
a hard charging person but you hated it
because they drove you nuts they
expected so much from you they challenge
you you couldn't stand it meaning maybe
you weren't ready for it so this whole
idea about you know if I'm around the
right people I would change too only if
you have the courage to be neutral to
accept willing to improve to reason yes
if not your ego gets in the way your
pride gets in the way you feel sorry for
yourself apathy grief shame guilt any of
that stuff forget about it it's not it's
not gonna happen and last but not least
the third part which is the movie
against spoiler don't stick around if
you're gonna watch the movie The Whale I
see his speech he's getting the
emotional crying I'm like man I'm so
glad this guy is back yet put on weight
everybody forgot about Brandon Frazier
and now he crushes it with the acting
that he does Now movie story I don't
like the story I like Brandon Frazier
not the story so I'm criticizing the
story let me get into it should I go
watch this movie with Mario so Pat you
got to watch the movie The Wheel great
let's go watch it sitting there's a
story of a man who was married got a
daughter eight years old he's married to
a woman got a daughter eight years old
ends up falling in love with one of his
students and leaves wife and daughter to
be with this man
this man he ends up falling in love with
they end up being together ends up
committing suicide he puts on all this
weight is like five six hundred pounds
the sister of the man he falls in love
with becomes his caretaker so just kind
of following on what's going on here
anyways his doctor keeps saying you're
two weeks away from dying four weeks
away from dying because the way you're
eating he keeps eating pizza all this
stuff because he's just done with his
life right then all of a sudden out of
nowhere his daughter who resents him
because left him comes into his life and
there's that relationship but she's
bitter she's angry she's upset at him
how could you leave me all this other
stuff he says but you know what I have a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars
that's safe to give to you he's like I'm
going to give it to you all you need to
do is write all you need to do is do
this if you come here I'll help you with
your homework I'll help you with their
paper I'll help you with this and I'm
going to give you this hundred twenty
thousand dollars
and then at the end there's this scene
where the daughter is begging say I
don't care about your 120 000
begging the dad to change to choose to
change and lose the weight because he
can so he can see his daughter winning
so he can see his daughter's dreams
become a reality the daughter wants the
father to walk hit walk her down the
aisle one day you know how the movie
ends the movie and saying no no but this
is the right thing he dies leaves her
the money and the movie ends and the
credit shows up I'm sitting like what a
freaking stupid movie kind of a story is
this you want me to be inspired by this
uh you know what when life gets hard
screw it just give up and you know let
your life die your daughter loves you
but it's a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars
you know you're leaving 120 000 no that
movie is a movie that inspires other
people to think they can't change and
refuse to change even though your
daughter who's lived a miserable life
without a father figure they're always
in trouble the dad leaves for another
student a man and now that dad doesn't
want to change what's the moral of the
story you don't want to change
you don't want your daughter to have a
relationship with you don't want to
change see the whole reason why I'm
explaining this story the way I'm giving
it to you is because if you're still
watching this video at this point you're
feeling the pain of this video okay the
only thing that caused this lazy man to
change this guy up until 18 my dad only
thing he would say you're so lazy you're
so this you're so that you're lazy
eventually I watch my dad potentially
dying on his deathbed when he lost 40
pounds
and I said this is not going to happen
I'm going to give my ass to work it was
so freaking painful visualizing my dad
dying I was not willing to live with it
period I dropped certain habits I feared
success I feared failure I feared
embarrassment what if I can do it what
if I'm not good enough what if I'm not
smart I've had all the grief but you
don't know I went through my parents
went through a divorce but you don't
know my life all this [__] I read
this I'm like Don I'm doing this I'm
changing pain eventually got me to say
I'm going in the Army Force putting
myself in a situation that I don't have
a choice I have to be up at four o'clock
in the morning I have to work out I have
to run I have to be in shape I have to
be around all that stuff
a big decision with that now someone may
be watching said I'm 42 years old what
do you want me to do have a workout
partner and you work out with them at
six o'clock where you can disappoint
them hire a trainer you're paying them
money to get you to get up in the
morning create a seven o'clock breakfast
with potential prospects for you to see
create opportunities where you are being
held accountable in a situation where
you have to choose to change or else
because if you don't change
he can convince everybody life is hard
but eventually you're going to be a
certain age and you're going to look at
that person in the mirror and you're
going to say you're so full of [__]
that's very painful it's very painful if
you're okay with that go watch the whale
let that inspire you to not change
go watch the will and said you know what
I'm all about this
Pat's wrong some people are this some
people are dead no problem that's why I
said I don't know if you're going to
choose to change or not or if you're
watching and saying you know what I'm
sick of it maybe go buy the book power
versus Force
maybe go read maybe do certain things
that's going to put you in a place to
say I better get my act together maybe
paint a picture for yourself if you
don't change what life's going to look
like how painful is that you okay with
that your girl even your kid's not
wanting to see you you're being alone by
yourself if you're okay with that do
what you're doing
if you're not go light it up so I'm 50
50. on some that will change and some
that won't because 100 of it is on who
is on you so I got a video for you to
watch okay the video I want you to watch
this video I did four or five years ago
it's called how to improve your work
ethic if you've never watched this video
click here to watch the video take care
everybody bye
[Music]